it's time for screen junkies movie
fights Oh what in the world we are doing
this you guys happy fourth of July it's
America's birthday happy birthday
America and there's no better way to
celebrate than with a last fighter
standing movie fights throwdown Wow we
have assembled just a collection of
movie fighters that is going to make you
crap your pants it's so good and hashtag
movie fights live hashtag movie fights
pre-recorded it's a very special
America's birthday edition and the last
fighter standing today will walk out of
here with this thing the movie fights
championship belt Oh real quick got to
give a shout-out to Alan Asian percival
in the house hoot hoot and I will also
say that the next movie fights you know
this is our last weekly movie fights
then we were moving to monthly our next
one will be the movie fights from San
Diego comic-con that is always epic such
good times and then new show programming
a little switcheroo honest trailer
commentaries next week will be moving to
Wednesday mornings at 10:00 a.m. all
right so honest trailer commentaries
coming and if you're a member of alum
nation and you want to keep track of
that we are going to be dropping the owl
nation podcast myself and lawn Harris so
check that out wherever find podcasts
are sold but it's free so just yeah do
that alright so here's how this is going
to work we have assembled the greatest
movie fighters from the show's history
it is nuts and it's going to so you can
see them all spread out there on the
couch look at that array of talent that
make some noise
so here's how it works three competitors
will be randomly selected and they will
enter into the round the winner of that
round remains and it's like a king of
the mountain while two losers are gone
two more will come in and then the
winner of that round will stay and will
keep going it's gonna be rinse and
repeat for basically like five rounds
and then in the final round we'll pick
the two top fighters one will be
eliminated and they'll go into a speed
round best of five and whoever gets
three points of those out of those five
questions does that make sense yes no
don't worry you'll figure it out happy
birthday America have a hot dog drink a
beer it's gonna be a good time strap in
and helping us decide all of this we
have long Dan calling some regulations
how this is gonna go oh okay rules and
you said rules oscillations all out for
us oh I thought I just did let you know
we're all counting on you there it is
and Danielle so you are not there is no
live poll today because we aren't
pre-recorded yeah sorry to people but
please keep following on the movie bytes
live hashtag we will be going through
and checking them and talking about all
the stuff so please it's a really
exciting episode and we hope that
everybody gets to participate in the
hashtag I don't know why I brought my
laptop alright so you know in the mix we
have so many great fighters we have Dan
Merle the current movie fights champion
he's gonna be yeah there is Dan the man
this is some good stuff
you know what let's see who our first
three fighters are going to be all right
I'm gonna pull them out of a hat here we
have a Scott
[Applause]
sitting next days Cabrera will be my
biological father one of the few people
that can match that energy the master of
the speed round koi Chandra
[Applause]
before I asked jte can you drop that
sick ass package
[Music]
Thank You Thor I ask the question here's
how it works I will ask the question and
then shout out your answers like we're
in the speed round and then we will
fight regular movie-style there's no
time movie fight style no time limit so
shout out your answers I will write them
down and then we'll fight it out okay
here is the question question number one
what is the best movie that bombed at
the box we've run a Fight Club I'll say
children of men blaze my second guess
late runner fight club from coy ace has
children of men
all right fight it out you guys okay so
Blade Runner which came out on June 25th
1982 cost about 35 million dollars to
make made about 28 million dollars at
the box office this movie just has has
nobody was ready for it when it came out
in 1982 in a Harrison Ford who was very
famous a very popular because of two
Star Wars movies in Indiana Jones and
Ridley Scott the director his previous
film alien was a massive massive hit in
a very influential movie but Blade
Runner nobody knew what to make of it
based on a short story by philip k dick
Do Androids Dream of Electric Sheep it
was too cerebral it was too esoteric it
was too ambiguous and it just didn't do
well people didn't know what to make of
it there was a boring narration but then
over the years they took away the
narration and people started to discover
the movie on home entertainment on VHS
and then people realized how influential
it was you saw the impact that Blade
Runner in other films like Strange Days
children of men and and the revamp
Battlestar Galactica
it is the most influential science
fiction film ever made even topping 2001
a space on III I tend to agree that it
has a lot of influence but the movie
itself has a lot of flaws as well I mean
you mentioned a lot about why it didn't
connect with audiences the reason why is
because it was very slow and it's very
boring a lot of current audiences that
watched new generations that watch Blade
Runner now a priest
the cyberpunk genre appreciate the new
kind of genre the new sci-fi feel that
it introduces into new movies like a
Blade Runner 20 49 but the original
itself is still very slow it's still
very you know hard to get into as far as
a story itself your shoe's as far as
Harrison Ford connecting yeah it has a
lot of problematic issues as far as his
relationship in that movie
I feel like children of men is one of
the most current sci-fi movies as far as
what the themes that it's dealing with
the the initial principle of a sci-fi
movie is to show you issues that come up
in our world now and what could happen
to them in the future as far as
immigration as far as refugees that's
what children of men is all about and
that's what we're seeing nowadays and
that's what makes it a powerful sci-fi
movie not just that but the shots in
this movie are absolutely incredible
it's one of the greatest shots sci-fi
movies of all time there are multiple
wonders in this movie that just take you
far back the water inside the car inside
that car chasing is absolutely
incredible
I feel like children of men delivered
something that's so ahead of its time
that I feel like 10 20 years from now
we're gonna be looking at that movie as
another influential movie not just
because of what it did and what it
continues to do but what it initially
did when it first came out in theaters I
want to talk about movie that ahead of
time that is of course Fight Club 1999's
Fight Club cost way too much to make it
almost tank to studio no one knew what
to make of it no one knew how to market
it and that movie is still one of the
most misunderstood films because it
appeals to both the highest and lowest
common denominator society - people
don't like Fight Club for the fights
didn't get the movie the people don't
like Fight Club for the
anti-capitalistic nature for the actual
subtext for the actual way it sees the
world we're living in a nihilistic
society in that film that actually
doesn't feel like nihilism in the cliche
thesis Fight Club college student way
we're living in a world that actually
exists today we've had all these
problems that that Fight Club kind of
prophesized way back 20 years ago and
the ramifications that film still hold
up the way David Fincher's developed his
style really took off at Fight Club for
me David Fincher is in arguably one of
the best directors at a time and Fight
Club to me was him using all of his
powers the way she used CGI to blend
things that couldn't be done with actual
practical but you don't feel like it's
CGI the acting and that movie's
incredible it's Brad Pitt at its best
because Brad Pitt is a character actor
trapped in a Han
some man's body and he gets to be a
character actor trapped in Tyler
Burton's body it also is one of the rest
best representations of toxin
masculinity and that it is a character
who actually represents what men want to
be in the 90s and it destroys all
problems it has all of the subtext about
these films but doesn't have the pacing
issues has a great soundtrack he is
greatly directed and it's Ed Norton and
Brad Pitt at their best of about a
minute left about a minute left you guys
okay okay first of all first of all
you're breaking the two rules you're not
allowed to talk about Fight Club without
Blade Runner there would have been no
children of man thermo-skin fluency oh
so I agree but the Blade Runner is the
best movie because it was so influential
but because you're saying that it was
boring it was it was slowly paced but
the last half-hour of that film was not
stop action it had the greatest score
what are the greatest scores of any
movie by Vangelis or Vangelis or however
you pronounce his name it is a great
score and movie as longer relevant
themes about what does it mean to be
human there was always the question
about whether or not Deckard was a
replicant Harrison for most of
replicating a question that they still
answer and Harrison Ford is Deckard he
was a great antihero about the 30
seconds left
I remember moments of children amendment
I mainly remember that one sequence it's
not an overall film it's a lot of times
I enjoy the tones of that film Blade
Runner certainly has moments and it
definitely is influential but there's a
reason you see 87 cuts of that movie
show that it wasn't a complete film
there's a reason that didn't get well it
had to be remade you said it's down I
feel like a glorified Brad Pitt's
character essentially what
all right Spock do you Androids Dream of
Electric Sheep and will Scott dream of
what he did not say at the end of
anything factual you want to add there I
think it's Vangelis but the Internet is
very back and forth on hard versus soft
g1 thank you for that so I'll try mine
on this first three great answers I felt
like Scott got dinged and and there
weren't a lot of dings on coy and ace
here but just as far as that it being a
slower paced film and the pacing maybe
being a problem because it is a
throwback to the noir style I feel like
that does I don't know that is kind of a
mixed bag pacing wise and I heard just
more points Scott I feel like you relied
a little too much on the the influence
and the history of the film where's
these guys hit more tangible bullet
points as far as the full package just
as far as the influence the themes of
the movie and the individual scenes I
heard just by a hair
ace with children of men for me but coy
had a powerful argument as well but I'm
going ice long who do you got I met all
three halves my favorite pic but I think
he did a great job of arguing life's
most influential as opposed to the best
so it really came down to coy versus ace
I disagree a little I thought ace came
out really strong with a great sort of
opening about all the great aspects of
children man I thought you did a great
job talking about how you know
cinematography is so amazing but I
thought coy just with the complete
package it was a really he gave a really
interesting robust very thorough sort of
statement on why Fight Club was so ahead
of its time I think my own coy alright
it's 1:1 Danielle Radford
sorry mance once again I love like
you're so good at the dates and the
numbers and the everything but I think
that sometimes I wind up taking too much
of the argument instead of doing a wage
of the points and you did wind up being
too much about the influence so for me
it was also between those two and I have
to agree with mod just by a hair because
there were a few more specificities
I don't agree in real life but in this
fight I have to say I have to go with
with no worries you can beat traffic
okay
[Applause]
all right again there are no points
giving out giving out it's just just
stay on and whoever's on at the end gets
to go to the speed round for all the
marbles to the top of two who will COI
face first off and go here wherever you
like wherever you like and then DJ woes
so I saw this on the show in micro
counting on you said you brought to you
by airplane yes Roger Roger
what's your vector victor okay let's get
question number two again call out your
answer and we'll go from there
okay this is a good one
have you read what is the best nan MCU
superhero movie spider-man one Sam
Raimi's for spider-man The Dark Knight
blade - okay okay so and coy you at dark
night and then lon was blade - yeah okay
fight it out friends
all right so Sam Raimi's spider-man one
is the movie we'd already had played
we'd already had x-men but Sam Raimi's
first spider-man movie was the movie
that launched superhero movies as we
know them it took the best elements of
past superhero movies by perfecting the
origin of Peter Parker we'd already seen
the origin story done and Richard Donner
Superman spider-man perfected that we'd
already seen a movie done with style
with Batman Tim Burton keep the same
Raimi's spider-man perfected that as
well by the way you might have heard the
Bell Thank You ed Grier for stepping
into lon
it was the first film to show much like
we've learned that Netflix series that
your hero's only as good as the villain
the Dark Knight was able to give us both
the and my opinion definitive take on
the Joker because it was like nothing
else we'd ever seen more camels Mark
Hamill awesome right there and give him
or Kevin some of the African action I
think he'd Ledger's Joker really
transcended the medium there's a reason
it's the first one getting a major
Academy Award nod and win there's a
reason that film is taken so seriously
there's a reason Chris Nolan - spoken
and all these circles and there's a
reason that we see the Dark Knight
trilogy for what it is Batman Begins is
a great start it really escalates and
turns into Dark Knight Dark Knight Rises
certainly not the part of that trilogy
we're talking about well the thing that
Dark Knight did was it painted a picture
of an actual police procedural drama and
put Batman in it that is on a superhero
movie it's more than a superhero movie
and that's why it's the best out of the
MCU it's arguably better than the MCU
cumulatively because it shows the MCU
how to do it right and Batman has never
been more Batman the Joker is everything
for Joker and there's to face everything
about that movie is everything we love
about Dark Knight and it's perfect Dark
Knight is a good Joker movie as
superhero movie where there's nothing
procedural bad there's no procedure it's
just a bunch of random incidents happen
that Batman has to go like sort of tera
Gatien scene so but there's no police
investigation that you're finding what
is the investigation like oh I bet
there's some ships we better go look at
of it Joker's about to show up at this
party like the police are pawns it's not
about them doing a great job
you're coming investigating yeah exactly
like the superhero comic mystery we're
at one film is a comic book super story
it's also a horror film and it's also a
great Guillermo del Toro movie and
that's Blade 2 what these folks don't
have these folks have great directors
that have taken their style and made it
very subtle so that they can service
this very well-known famous story
spider-man doesn't feel like the
definitive Sam Raimi film and Dark
Knight doesn't feel like the definitive
Christopher Nolan film but Blade 2 is
very immediately recognizable it has
monsters it has a creepy very thoughtful
and carefully built out world that it
takes place in it's got supernatural
feels is clearly a Guillermo del Toro
movie it's about feeling different it's
about feeling
isolated intimate feeling alienated and
it works perfectly well as a superhero
comments and nobody is connecting to
blade or our Christian Bale's Batman in
those movies as human beings I remember
as a young man going seeing spider-man 1
and seeing myself reflected on the
screen somebody struggling with becoming
adult somebody struggling with finding
RUC's the key of spider way which is why
spider-man is so appealing
whereas both both Dark Knight and blade
treat their characters with such a
distance that it's more about the movies
themselves about the characters and
putting yourselves with cookie cutter
high school we've seen that done better
in spider-man homecoming yeah that's
meant homecoming fix that spider made
Tony Stark's teen sidekick hi spider-man
is a supporting character in those
movies we don't come and take spider-man
it actually makes Peter Parker's high
school relatable and feel little past 30
year old CW
in high school and so did Flash Thompson
who was this Lee was a 35 year old
wandering the high school hallways I
never bought that spider-man same to me
we look at it with nostalgia glasses and
I find ivory watch it's amazing Gemma
del Toro made a great gamble del Toro
movie not a great blade all of your
points I think work against that film
because I never felt like I watched a
blade movie I felt like I watched blade
and I was so great as the Green Goblin
he's able to project through that silly
mask where is the Power Rangers villain
they wasted Norman Osborn they wasted
castings in both Batman and the Joker
that's the beauty of a disaster Joker
it's a movie about a villain and how you
take care of that villain it's
escalating thirty Seconds the end of
Edmund begins set up an archetype you
leave because of escalation so yes it's
move about a villain no one else did
that great infinity war why is that a
bad thing is a beautiful film that lands
that beautifully where the Sam Raimi
spider-man is a samurai movies at home
so also is a movie that's able to stand
on its own it's not a sequel blade one
to see blade twos like oh this guy's a
vampire but I'm alright Wow
nobody here that was a barnburner okay
Danielle Radford what are you thinking
about this one again these were all
fantastic arguments I'm very glad that
Tony didn't could jump up and be very
happy I see far from home a lot
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay so much as the arguments ago all of
these were these were great arguments I
think that DJ unfortunately sometimes
you would undercut yourself by talking
about how great spider-man was been
unnecessarily great how great spider-man
was in the movie and you would mention
how William Dafoe had to overcome the
mask and some of the silly stuff and for
me I felt like that kind of undercut
your argument with with quois argument
man I that was one where every time you
would love one that I would be like out
of the park lawn would catch it like
one-handed I miss like you know talking
about how it's a procedural and he
mentions there isn't a really any
procedure both of them gained you want
it's a good supervillain movie so on
that I gotta go with lon
all right that's one that's one
okay their facts in there you know what
overall I mean the weird part is koi had
the best movie but I don't know yeah
maybe not best argument in regards to he
had a procedural jazz like oh I was with
you and then like he puts together a
bullet with the help of supercomputer
and some donuts with some cops for no
reason yeah I don't like that that sucks
um so and then blade to being such a alt
or movie you mean I
that was nice that was nice stuff but DJ
I don't say I think DJ talked a lot
about why spider-man why that's the best
not MCU because it really kept to the
character he got some good points in it
about like it's not be holding anything
it's not a sequel so I got a break from
the pack and go DJ okay so it's one
phone one for DJ yeah there were these
were great choices great arguments all
around but the one that I heard the
least just powerful takedowns
against that at the same time had a very
strong opening salvo an argument
throughout I've got to go with long
blade - that just came out
most honest days marah's everybody was
just throwing haymakers Milan came out
that's a little bit the cleanest so I
[Applause]
can't think alright so let's see who's
gonna jump in these hot seats no bursa
oh yeah we're just talking about um the
Tony rebel our fire man he hates Peter
Parker okay
yeah they are not messing around
[Music]
is the most thing all right so has the
bath ready now because now you've never
held the movie fights title but you have
held the bathroom key for this building
for the longest out of anyway I'm
suffering for it this man has it right
now all right
why do you check your pockets here we go
question number three okay we ask what
is David Fincher's best filter Nanak
okay I heard a Zodiac yeah what was the
other I heard social network social
network ok social network from Tony and
lon
I'll go 7 ok
okay so we have seven from LAN we have
social network from Tony and from Greg
we have zodiac gentlemen let's fight it
out zodiac with the David venture he
always likes to explore a lot of this
psychology of things and especially with
the serial killer element and you know
the anima brought up the movie seven
what I love the most about zodiac is how
human the film is it's not really about
the serial killer so much it's more
about our obsession with serial killers
and that's kind of a brave topic to
actually explore I can't tell you how
many people I know just like look up
true crime and love to investigate these
sort of things and you watch these
characters with like Jake Gyllenhaal
Robert Downey jr. Mark Ruffalo you're
seeing their personal lives deteriorate
over the course of the film just because
of their one obsession with a real-life
serial killer on top of that - it's even
though it's a quiet film it will still
have this like haunting score and it'll
be the most beautifully scripted film
out of any of his movies and the
production design of it he brings that
era to life and you feel how the world
is being affected there so yeah I think
it's just a super thrilling movie but
that's really not the as you said
yourself it's not really about the
circular it's about like how slow and
painful a slog it is to try to underlie
that and that sounds kind of an
unsatisfying movie minutes kind of the
whole point I was watching these guys
ruin their lives on this investigation
that maybe ultimately doesn't matter I
sort of agree it's kind of like a
takedown of the true crime job whereas
seven is sort of the iconic serial
killer movie that all the other serie
come where movies that came out in the
later 90s and year laughs we're all
trying to like rip off and get back to
what Fincher did with seven I disagree
completely that the movie is like a slow
boring film it's a character study of it
your movie also has Kevin Spacey in it
because they already knew pre actively
don't put that guy in the credits of
your movie
thanks for wanna take them out later so
it's actually very forward-thinking and
with social network I feel like that's
more now in script is more of the
highlight for that movie than it is more
of the direction of David Fincher Evan
Walker now you're took Andrew Kevin
Walker yes I was thinking of the Danny
Boy Tony I would love to hear some
thoughts I was gonna come in but I think
okay you were saying it's more of a
human story this is about the social
network was about as humanists can get
with a guy trying to create Facebook and
and making that story appealing is
incredible yes he's made two films about
serial killers but let's be honest the
best serial killer film of all time a
sentence of the lens which every film is
trying to live up to albeit that's
different so I'm saying albeit but I
think seven is better than Zodiac
because I do agree that like this is
just watching people fall into the that
obsession or whatever but that's
relatable movie but I think what makes
social network David Fincher's best
movie is not only from every line of
dialogue that you can just remember and
you're hooked from the second it starts
to Jesse Eisenberg's pitch perfect
performance as Mark Zuckerberg I think
it genuinely sets it off who have a
possibly oscar-winning performance from
Justin Timberlake someone who really had
never wanted to do a humanizing story
I'm awful guy I do really I also feel
like I make a great movie matter how
wonderful it is that nevermind elections
and democracy spine let's take that out
because that is not the part of the film
species in my Zuckerberg performance to
the thing I'm a see and and Facebook's
dealing with box or whatever but the
Mark Zuckerberg personality and I think
Jesse Eisenberg fails to actually
portray that when we have when we have
Mark Zuckerberg personality all over the
internet and then you see Jesse
Eisenberg personality though he's not
doing Mark Zuckerberg I would disagree I
think what you're saying we knew what
would Mark Zuckerberg personality I
don't like a whole bunch of interviews
that was not the general public and lead
either but that's the point he made a
story with an unlikable lead and you
still kind of want him to succeed and
and I think both of your movies are more
of a good observational piece whereas I
think zodiac actually puts you into it
along emotionally you connect more 1:7
than you do with zodiac which is very
much a I'm totally connected
people who follow Meryl Adler's then I
do connect with two detectives no I
guess I connect with the people who are
trying to we're living through Facebook
and showing your relationship and how
you grow and how this started not only
do you get more information from actual
real life but now year now you're also
like very fictional more real than than
a serial killers or people falling you
know into movies are based on truth our
movies deal with obsession and deals
with obsession this is the one that is
most relatable in understanding the
mindset of people who do fall down that
path down that path that far but seven
is also a movie about people who become
under minded and who in ruins their mind
they become so fixated on solving this
case but it does it in a more engaging
emotionally entertaining way the
characters in in in the social network
all interact so beautifully and so
realistically more than any of your two
films that they just I don't know it's
it's a great idea I completely disarmed
so much good stuff right here you know
at the end of lon your argument against
against Greg that didn't really feel
like a takedown it was just like kind of
summation of like the tone of his film
and I am feeling so that takedown didn't
quite work for me so at the end of the
day I heard the most individually about
their movies from Tony and gray and we
looked a mess of like it
Rowdy curly hair
Oh a couple of handsome fellas down the
end there and at the end I thought
Gregg's
opening salvo and then how he parried
throughout took the day for him in my
books I'm going with Greg and zodiac
even though Tony had some wonderful
stuff to say about social network LAN I
like your choice as well but Greg and
Greer I think I'm gonna break away from
the pack let's say you know what these
you guys I see why you guys always say
oh great arguments all around because
guess what their work yeah I really and
this is the best of the best so
obviously it's gonna be that way
personally I gotta say I like seven the
best but taking that out of it I like
what Tony was saying about the
filmmaking mastery it would take to make
somebody like Zuckerberg appealing at
the main character of a movie and I
think the only the only things that the
lawn did to knock out was just the Jazz
about it being like unrequited story of
finding the dude if I want to watch a
movie about finding a dude you better
find the dude okay so it's one for Gregg
one for Tony Danielle all right so with
this one I felt like part of this fight
got way too into the weeds with you know
for a while it felt like it was a bit
like best serial killer fight and like
that was what the fight was about
and then it became about things with
just like you know other stuff besides
we may seven with Christopher Plummer
the specific arguments about the movies
were lost I I do agree you know and I
was going in one direction but lon did
have that great takedown of if you're
gonna if this is a movie about fighting
the guy I wonder what you find the guy
and so it was between Greg and Tony for
me because I felt like they were really
specific about their movies law and
wanted up knocking Greg out so I'm going
with
[Applause]
let them knock each other out
yeah each other out right okay
so let's find out it's round number four
who will be joining Tony or ever Lori up
here in the hot seats
first off oh here he comes Dan
this right here belongs to Dan but it is
on the line it's anybody's ballgame
right now and in the third seat come on
down Cameron right
all right okay gentlemen I will ask the
question number four and just shout out
your answers oh boy okay so fun ones uh
what movie character would stand the
best chance to win the Hunger Games
grumble ring okay we have the Hulk huh
you said Wolverine I said Wolverine
Wolverine Tony Mark Zuckerberg and what
movie character movie character yes we
have Wolverine Hulk
okay Wolverine Hulk I have no idea lon
you make great choices choose from your
Superman would be a good choice okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Oh matters we go so we have Wolverines
Superman and Hulk in The Hunger Games
fight it out who would be the best I'm
sorry can I just like ask what's the
setting or does that matter or are we
arguing our own jungle tracker jackers
Thanks character would stand the best
chance to win the Hunger Games and I'm
assuming it's just our three cuz we keep
Katniss in there I mean there's
literally nothing that can hurt Superman
besides magic which is obviously
something he doesn't have any resistance
to none of these characters have any
magic in them the the man can fly into
the Sun and become Superman a million
come back and destroy the entire planet
even without doing that so and he can
survive in the atmosphere so there's
none of these characters that can stand
up to him surviving in the atmosphere
and flying to the Sun not good skills to
have for the Hunger Games and he does
have another weakness that would be
kryptonite and what can you do if you're
in The Hunger Games rich people from
outside of the world can send things
into the Hunger Games hoping once the
outcome and who's richer than Lex Luthor
you know he'd be sending kryptonite
arrows to every single other person I
think I love them
first of all you have the opening
ceremony and who's gonna dress the best
thank you is very likeable the Hulk as
the Hulk if he's Bruce Banner maybe but
he's still nerdy and people don't really
root for him he is the person he is the
tribute that everyone sees and when they
fight Superman is that tribute so of
course they're gonna be paying for him
as much as Lex Luthor has money I'm sure
a bunch of other people would be sending
Superman and he doesn't even need them
if they give by the way I don't know if
Wolverine or Hulk know how to fire an
arrow or even use kryptonite it is a
hundred earlier he's an outdoors I feel
like a fool I think it's too prideful to
even want to use this is that five years
between a end game and infinity or an
end game this is when we're getting kind
of smart Hulk but he's still a little
angry little powerful he knows how to
shoot an arrow
I know so not just okay I'll help you
with Superman's I'm gonna help me with a
Superman thing a little bit over here is
that Superman it's all about computers
all that stuff - that's how they work
Brainiac in the computer he's screwed
adding supervillain perhaps add william
stryker let's add Superman you can send
stuff like a gun with a silver bullet
Superman can go BAM boom you're dead
smile Superman coming you can hide in
Superman of light like there's a doesn't
matter it goes green cannot that match
his speed his strength in anyway yeah
same with the hole the hole can maybe
matches strength maybe that's okay
there's not a quick rush of over a dozen
Cybermen in the film's he might wake up
heal but he does get knocked down we
wake up he'll go nuts you say Kitty
snikt right into the Hulk's heart
Superman can reverse time you can see
through adamantium and sees a weak point
in the joints and be able to like figure
out every counterpoint to be able to
beat the and if he doesn't need to cheat
to win he doesn't need to reverse time
so you can win straight out he go there
saying that that he wouldn't use a
kryptonite that they sent him in the
church not cheated not cheating that is
fair play according to the rules of the
game and Superman's a smart character
who knows what to do and be able to
manipulate things and he Superman would
never shoot someone was a gun he's
Superman well then he'd use the boy put
it on his finger in this Jabba's
business
they're fighting to the death and
Superman has to do this this is like
we're not talking about their character
if they're fighting to the death because
they have to die so the gun though
Superman doesn't kill so therefore it's
gonna be like Peter he's not gonna kill
anybody I'm just saying none of these
guys have the strength to shoot a
kryptonite arrow at the speed that he
can't dodge yet not if he was Superman
has faith in people that's his weakness
does nothing my god Lily couldn't do it
and Wolverine is it again if he goes
into preser commode maybe he's a little
bit stronger but again every every
Superman has a strength and speed to
counter anything and everything they do
even with outside help you have the
killer instinct for their rich people
consistent over talking guys rich people
can send things I'm gonna say that they
send the Hulk of the Infinity Gauntlet
[Music]
I'm just saying I don't know if any rich
person would have the ability to buy or
be able to send in and Infinity Gauntlet
especially after this one in order and a
real Infinity Gauntlet
[Laughter]
just about power it's about skill and it
is I mean you know Wolverine has the
desire to kill
Hulk goes into berserk courageous but he
makes mistakes it gets all mixed up plus
if you could bring out banner if
Superman can get to this better human
instincts and then Hulk is sort of
missed and again Wolverine will jump out
of a tree and stab it with his claws
right Superman will you Hulk has lost a
Superman plenty of times and Wolverine
has lost a whole plenty of time so it's
Hulk can be raised or so beaten Hulk yes
but no one none of those two have ever
beat Superman and I'll be I know those
are in the comic it's not the movies are
you talking comics or movies are
everything between well we're talking
comics I'm gonna bring in the ultimate
swear the whole combination of skill
kill killer instinct and what a second
to win the game the intelligence
everything that you need to win the
Hunger Games is all right there and
we'll absolutely same with a Superman
everything you say and if push comes to
shove push comes to shove he can
absolutely kill people if he needs to
and he has I'm pretty sure he yes
crying about it there two babies yeah
time you know what all these dudes are
jacked all right Brock Lesnar of the
world everything about the DC Marvel
coming together good times thank you
thank you for that be a space stone one
please go ahead and chime in oh great
great points all around I think Alan
convinced me that Hulk would make the
best sartorial choices
Tony convinced me that Superman could
win if this was just a straight-up
Battle Royale but I thought when you
talk about specifically who would win
the Hunger Games and they then went
above and beyond really specific
arguments about why Wolverine is best
poised to win this specific tournament
I'm going down yeah lon I felt similarly
I mean Dan went into like just Wolverine
was an outdoorsman he's a tracker even
both went into how he shops an REI
and we heard a lot about the powers and
how like jacked er dudes were and
specifically tailoring it not too
sartorial choices but to the Hunger
Games yeah dan Merle takes this one
Cameron Tony well played that is canon
Oh Tony I want to alright dudes and
right now we have an old pal with us
we haven't haven't had him on the show
in a while he hasn't been here but I'm
so thrilled and just touched that he's
come down to talk to us and be here
today so without further ado mr. Roger
bar Roger
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome hello hello eat your rock
so they're the reason I'm here is
basically I believe in you know trying
to use you know if you have a platform
trying to use it for good and I haven't
been here in quite a while and it's it's
unfortunately a kind of a tragic story
but I want to tell you guys what
happened and explain a little bit for
those of you who don't already know the
reason I've been gone so long is back in
November of 2017
my wife Marie she uh she ended her life
long battle with clinical depression by
taking her own life she was the love of
my life and I'm beyond devastated I
don't understand how I'm in a world that
she's no longer a part of a world where
I can't share all those wonderful laughs
and adventures with my favorite person
with my love that's her on the screen
right there yeah um she's my best friend
I don't understand why I have to wear
her reading her wedding rings around my
neck rather than stand by her side and
hold her in my arms I'm no longer the
same person and the reality is two
people died that day and I do feel like
a ghost my life has gotten a lot smaller
since then and I do miss all of you but
I'm here again because I wanted to talk
to all of you about depression because
it's what she would have wanted me to do
depression is an awful disease and
having spent over 20 years of my life
with her I saw how often it clouded her
mind and lied to her she was so
incredibly brave in her fight against
her depression and social anxiety from
trying medications and therapies to
exercising and eating healthy and so
much more her entire life she confronted
all of it head-on in a fearless manner
and I couldn't be more proud of her I
admired her so much and I still do and I
always will
the fact is reoww she was the strongest
person I've ever known a hell of a lot
stronger than me she was everything I
ever aspired to be and she made me a
better person
but depression is a ruthless liar all
too often it clouded her mind and made
her believe she wasn't a good person or
cared about or worthy of love it made
her believe she was a burden rather than
beloved it's a disease that lies in
ruins lives it's no longer it's no
different than cancer and just like
cancer it's a disease that needs to be
fought not only by those afflicted with
it but by their friends and families
suicide and depression has such a stigma
associated with them and we all need to
be willing to talk about these subjects
openly that's the only way those who
struggle with severe depression are
going to get to help they really need
think about it the disease makes those
afflicted with it feel lonely enough as
it is
just imagine how lonely people with
depression feel when they believe they
can't even talk about it with their
friends loved ones
honestly it's up to friends and family
to bring it up because those who
struggle with depression often don't
have the strength to do so sometimes
it's a victory for them just to get out
of bed on any given day so if you know
somebody who struggles with it or you
even suspect they do please check in
with them see how they're doing see if
there's anything you can do to help and
above all else listen to them really
listen to what they have to say in our
twenty years together Rhee and I talked
constantly about her struggles with the
disease and now that she's gone all I'm
left is with is what-ifs what if I done
this what if I'd done that always
wondering what more I could have done to
save the love of my life say what you
will but I'll always see this as the
most devastating failure of my life I
believe it was my my purpose to keep her
alive with my love and I failed to do so
that's something I now have to learn to
live with and it's something I have to
carry with me and hopefully I can
somehow help other people along the way
and make her proud
helping other people mattered so much to
her and that's one of the reasons why
I'm here today because it's what she
would have wanted
I've spent a long time writing an
ongoing story about REE because I wanted
the world to see just how amazing warm
talented creative beautiful and loving
she was in life I also wanted the world
to understand just how much devastation
the disease of depression can cause
regardless of how truly wonderful or
successful a person is I wanted to share
what I've been through during that time
as well so people could understand the
collateral damage that depression and
suicide does and I wanted to share the
things I've been doing to honor her
memory since she passed as much as I'd
like to read that story to all of you
today it would take up this entire show
and then some so I'd like all of you to
save the URL that's should be on your
screen right there yeah I - Mochrie comm
/r II and visited tomorrow or whenever
you have time to sit down and read
through it it's not an easy read but
it's an important one especially if you
or somebody you know struggles with
depression suicidal thoughts or loss it
would mean a lot to me and I hope it
will mean a lot to some of you after
you've read it in closing I always
consider myself very lucky to have an
outlet like this show where I could make
such a wonderful audience laugh while
performing alongside such other
hilarious talented like-minded friends
debating on behalf of all the movies
we're all into as a comedy writer who
spends most of his time in solitude
behind a computer screen I can't tell
you how nice it has always been to get
out of the house and have some laughs
with all of you including you just
watching it's always been wonderful
conversing with so many of you on
Twitter over the years and I really
can't thank you enough for making this
weirdo feel a little Wes weird I mean
not really but it's it's nice knowing
weirdos like myself have good company
out there I miss making all of you laugh
and I miss laughing with you too but I'm
just not there yet I'm not in any shape
to to debate or anything and you have
plenty of performers here to do just
that and they'll do it better than I
probably could anyway it still hasn't
been two years since she passed
when you lose the love of your life
someone you love more deeply than you
ever imagined possible
it's not like there's a simple switch
you can flip to return to normal because
normal no longer exists still I do hope
to return sometime because I've always
been a hopeful person when it comes to
the future so in the meantime please
read that story when you have a chance
keep reading your hearts take care of
your loved ones and let's get back to
having some laughs here on movie fights
after all this is supposed to be a
celebration thanks so much for listening
thanks to everyone here at screen
junkies for giving me an outlet and
thanks for showing your support for me
all these wonderful years I love you
guys
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I just want to thank you for being
here my heart just breaks and your nuri
yeah absolutely and but to see you
having the strength to use this platform
to increase awareness and to let people
to attempt to end the stigma to
encourage people to get help and to you
know and to reach out that's so
important and I'm really proud of you
and I thank you so much for being here
thank you - I appreciate it
whenever you're ready to come back
there's always a spot for you here you
appreciate I know that because yeah um
you belong with us weirdos absolutely
I'll be there at Comic Con so I'm seeing
you guys there yeah thank you brother
thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah let's talk about some stupid [ __ ]
now all right which Winklevoss when
would Cameron is our primary Cameron
Winklevoss is the Gaggia thank you all
right all right now we're gonna jump
back into the fun whoa this is the final
round before we go to the speed round to
decide at all step it out of the booth
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and you just heard her chiming in Sasha
[Applause]
to pro-life better be keanu question
haha we shall see
alright the final table at the World
Series of Poker or so here we are top
two will move on to the speed round
alright so we're at the last round and
we're changing it up this round so
instead of two yeah but I said that I
just read what's in front of me there's
two winners will go into speed round
here is question yes okay I feel like I
said that like three different say it
again one more for safety
okay gone go to the two-shot Billy just
like you cut it back seat directly yeah
alright so on this being the last round
to get to the speed round we gotta
change it up a little flippy do so
instead of eliminating two we will
eliminate one after this round and then
the two fighters left standing
oh yeah we don't like standing on the
show sitting
we'll move on we should not have called
this last fighter standing okay so the
the quote-unquote worst answer I hate to
say that because we've got nothing but
good answers this whole damn game but
the the the one fighter will be
eliminated in the final two gone to the
speed round y'all ready for this let's
do this question number five what movie
that doesn't have one would inspire the
best ride John wick
fart fart bait okay we have John wick we
have speed and thor ragnarok
okay thor ragnarok all right so we have
Thor Ragnarok John wick from jte and
speed from Sascha fight it out alright
first of all whenever I go to university
O's in the world is always that game
like spider-man where you get to gone
you have a gun and you're basically on a
track you're going through and you're
shooting things you just don't feel
motivated you're just like I'm just
playing some stupid laser tag what if
you're going through the Continental and
you have a hologram canneries like go in
there then killed my dog
help me you're going in there and you're
like holy crap okay so I got Keanu as my
host I'm shooting people
first while I be headshot is worth
double the points because that's John
wick fashion and you give it like little
stuffed animal puppy as you enter the
ride and you're basically your job is to
keep this thing live there's a sensor on
all the things are actually shooting at
you
you can't die you're just like all right
I'm just gonna shoots try to get some
points you gotta keep that puppy alive
you cannot let him die surely disturbing
listen John wick is in fortnight he has
broken barriers now kids love them don't
sell them Sasha loves I do love him but
here's the thing if you're walking on it
I believe you Kiana Yuki on it with a
bomb on the bus and you have a whole
busload of people people who are married
with children have families they're here
just visiting Los Angeles for the first
time they want to have an experience
they want to die they want to die in the
hands of a madman
this is like the most incredible go-kart
ride you have ever had it is 50 miles an
hour the weeping your hair you Sandra
Bullock but your Sam are you on a hustle
we're on a bus and you want to go fast
you are Sandra Bullock I spent so many
years on the LA buses I don't want to go
back
it's going over the run is this robbery
but is a fully immersive 4d experience
the artist we're going to a discard
you're going across the Rainbow Bridge
arena you're moving it's like the hair
around your moon yeah through it's a 4d
experience is the entire throw you're
going different worlds you go through
wormholes it's fun
it's it's something you can't actually
do in the real world I don't want to
ride a bus and that is an insult to John
wick my friend John Mike would never
hand a gun to someone go here do my job
for me
work your way through the riders a
little huge line and as you fight this
is what I love is when they give you
story as you're waiting to get on so
you're sitting there you're gonna
comment also news like a news report
come on the local Kennel has been robbed
dogs are running
[Applause]
on the bus they're the most depressed
people they come together as a family
and then at the end of the bus ride
you've kicked down that little like
speak heart thing you tie it to the end
you get into Keanu's arms wanna talk
about a 40 experience
you smell make each other feel like
yo-yos playing you skitter across the
airplane Keanu experienced it's got to
go over 50 wooded you've ever been on a
bus in Los Angeles that went over 50
that's why you many buses they go over
50 like in a 30 mile an hour zone it's
not know what
go ask Carly we're in like 15 different
worlds and yeah
Ragnarok takes place in several places
go to a bride and do that when you go on
like the teacup ride you're in a teacup
we know it's like very Wonderland
you're in Al's wonderland you go to like
the tea party there's nothing budget for
these sorts of things are you kidding me
this isn't Disney they have the budget
they can make this in a tire park it
would cost by putting $1 and make it
back in a day laughs future disney cars
the cars right now imagine that bigger
with kion it's a souvenir you get an
actual puppy to get to name yeah we'll
just stop puppy to the ride just like
the et ride you give the name and as you
leave cat who says thanks for saving
spot congratulations you killed spy
there's a fail-safe
anytime you're about to get to long life
CGI or hologram count comes in and saves
the dog we're gonna get off for us we're
gonna ride the horse through the streets
and you are while we're shooting people
on my right has steaks my right my right
it's romantic my right has actually gone
over there because you're driving the
bus and he's right over your shoulder
off your time and your he's like can you
be my wife
[Applause]
shocking thing was that JT had a lot
more crap to talk about buses than all
right so a lot of fun stuff right there
you guys
Daniel Radford are what your thoughts on
this one you know as much as I want to
take my eye out on a bus I just kept
getting dinged because it feels like you
this okay well they can actually shoot
at you we can't give up we're never
gonna give you a puppy okay but a real
puppy you just have the clearest idea of
where your fake 20 seconds was so I have
to because of that that Sasha and dance
will be moving on it that was my comment
okay Danielle going with Sasha and Dan
yeah JT we leaned a little too - just
the preamble before you get to the ride
as well like like the Terminator ride
has that just like what did you say
about the ASPCA
but the dog was too much you can never
kill the doctor like yes and the
screenwriting chestnut saves the cat
JT but you will not be moving on to the
speed round
[Applause]
we are starting off at zero to zero the
speed round is the best-of-five the
first person to three points wins this
thing the movie fights championship belt
alright so again I'll ask the question
shout out your answers then once we have
your answers we'll get 20 seconds you'll
get 20 seconds to elaborate in the order
that you answer then 10-second rebuttals
y'all ready for this question number one
of the speed round Star Wars or Star
Trek Star Wars Star Trek I knew that
that's why I gave it to you weird Star
Wars first from Sasha Star Trek dan is
on deck with that Sasha 20 seconds begin
when you speak Star Trek and I feel like
Scott mans is gonna see screaming I
think that Star Wars speaks more to the
four quadrants you have child and you
have children you have adults you have
women you have men there is more of a
sense of true family in the Star Wars
movies there is more of a sense of
camaraderie there is a brotherhood that
is more that is left out of the Star
Trek movies Star Trek Star Wars has been
coasting off of one game-changing movie
that came out over 40 years ago that's
all it's been doing since there is a
good original trilogy the prequels
weren't great and I don't even know
what's going on with these new movies
the spin-offs are hidden miss yes Star
Trek has some films in the filmography
that aren't great but it continues to be
about big ideas about humanity about the
relationships between people not Blazers
fighting in space and not big opera
we're a family oh yeah big ideas like
saving whales
listen there's better action series it
truly gained do you want talk about
game-changing trilogies Star Wars
continues to deliver time after time
after time and Star Trek continues to
just be the cerebral
starwars continues to be a regurgitation
of what it was 40 years ago time after
time after time
Star Trek continues to make new movies
with new cast that reinvigorates the
franchise every 20 years and yes saving
who else love the best Star Trek movies
time all right
lawn Harris yeah both great arduous but
I feel like they just had he was ready
for this one he's really in the back on
the one good movie forty years ago crack
which is a really good one I got to go
Dan yeah I thought a little bit
differently because Dan danger Sasha on
uneven Star Wars films but then Dan um
deemed himself we said yeah some Star
Trek films are not that great and I
thought Sasha hit just the likability
and the action that Star Wars has
provided over the years so by a hair I'm
going Sasha so it's on my shoulders for
this one point out of five alright so
yeah both great points i I wanted you
know I think that dad really had it when
he mentioned you know was posting off of
one movie which I didn't feel like Sasha
had a really great comeback to hers was
a lot about how cerebral it was and the
four quadrants but I feel like Dan was
bringing stuff up that Sasha wasn't
hitting down as much especially like the
new movies with the new casts and going
off of their old stuff and so just in
the debate version the debate portion
I've gotta go down alright that is one
point for Dan here's question two of the
speed around what is the best serious
Jim Carrey movie role The Truman Show
Truman Show um the man on the moon man
on the moon
all right we have Truman Show with Dan
going first with that Sasha on deck with
man on the moon not only is it a great
performance in The Truman Show but it
was that when he had to break out of
this thing that people saw him as a
funny man and they didn't think he could
pull off a dramatic role he did and the
despair that you have this guy whose
entire world crumbles around him the way
he's able to bring you into that to play
the character of Truman he plays himself
not wanting to give away that he knows
what's going on he's able to play all
levels of deception the absolute sheer
terror tactic tackle an iconic role that
is the clown with tears I think is one
of the hardest things that you can ever
do Melosh Forman ended up giving us a
film that is beautiful it is
heartbreaking you deal with comedy you
deal with tragedy it is he was largely
still being the funny guy when you have
to see him in man on the moon you see
the true depths of despair that he had
to hit in a way that made him man on the
moon was a brilliant imitation of Andy
Kaufman and his beat for beat an
imitation of his greatest bits in his
greatest moments The Truman Show is a
fully fleshed original character that he
himself constructed I think that's more
impressive that's like saying it's easy
to play Muhammad Ali playing Andy
Kaufman is the hardest thing you could
ask a comedian to do and the truth is is
that Truman doesn't make the turn until
halfway through the second act and it
really is not that heartbreaking what
you're seeing is a man time all right
[Applause]
also acceptable would have been internal
sunshine and swallows mine okay
Daniel Radford what are your thoughts on
this this was a great back-and-forth
good lord both of you were able to hit
on how heartbreaking he was being and
that he had to play on different levels
of roles dan who did great when he
mentioned the original imitation how
Truman his original character that
Muhammad Ali lied fought back really
hard it's like you can't just be
Muhammad Ali and any compliment you like
you can do an impression but he like
became Andy Kaufman and it's a really
hard do to do an impression of you can't
just bust him out like a walk in I'm
going with Sasha on this one all right
that's one for Sasha blonde Harris yeah
really strong and sort of everything I'm
also go with Sasha all right great roman
in sports question number three of the
speed round better Batman Michael Keaton
or Christian Bale Michael Keaton okay
Dan with Keaton Sasha with Bale Dan
you're on the clock 20 seconds ago when
you talk Michael Keaton continues to be
the only Batman that'll been able to
pull off those Bruce Wayne and Batman in
a believable way Bale hid behind the
were assured persona Batman and it got
so ridiculous by the time you got to the
end of it he didn't even seem like a
character Michael Keene was able to play
Batman you could see the conflict but
underneath the sighs you could see Bruce
Wayne underneath that mask and that's
because Michael Keaton is such a great
actor I would argue person that does the
combination of both better is actually
Ben Affleck and I think that there's a
strong argument to be made there but if
we're gonna talk about the actual Batman
Christian Bale is better physically has
better physicality he is better in the
charisma of being the actual like the
savior of the night he is the person who
you believe can swoop in and actually
save you I think Michael Keaton's ass
you kidding me
Christian Bale I would love to see
anyone try to keep kick Michael Keaton's
ass he could scrap now and he could
certainly scrap 30 years ago and he
played Batman Bale got lost in the
persona Batman as where as Michael
Keaton was able to play the role they
all was able to go toe-to-toe with Heath
Ledger Dale's able to go toe-to-toe with
Aaron Eckhart talk about Batman CEO
Birdman he's already beat down he was
already like tires he was already
playing to watch another comedy
Christian bill have to pay this time
some some good stuff right here you know
it's not because of this but Michael
Keaton was recently at a college
graduation and I said I'm gonna leave
you with two words you just framed the
total package a little bit better Sascha
I loved your point about Christian
Bale's physicality being stronger but oh
I just got that much more from Dance I'm
going Dan Danielle because like Sasha
did she have great points about like the
physicality being able to be Batman but
I felt like it was too much too much
argument that being Bruce Wayne isn't as
important and I think you have to be
able to do both I think Dan gave me that
some glow with them there it is dan
takes that point all right belt dude I
don't even want it
[Applause]
belike this is Dansville that's now in
my house here we go question Sasha you
need this to tie it up so let's go
you need this to tie it up mine okay
here's a question what's the best movie
with either the number or the word one
in the title best movie well either the
number or the word one oh and does it
have to be it's it's it's it's on its
own either the number or the word does
it have to be I didn't write this
question he's like because like is
ocean's 11 okay then I will say Sidney
Lumet's 12 Angry Men
okay well it's better than what I was
gonna say which was Air Force One
for a minute there just I'll just note
they left 2001 a Space Odyssey on the
table alright so what happens when
you're 14 seconds no worries here we go
so again
sasha has Ocean's eleven Dean of the
original or the remake remakes the
remake and Dan has 12 Angry Men
Sasha 20 seconds begin when you speak
there has never been a more charismatic
ensemble put together than what we see
in Ocean's eleven Steven Soderbergh
brought together the best that you could
they bet she's ever done when it came to
both marketability and true art ISM he
got a performance out of George Clooney
that I would say is probably amongst his
best eye you have all the lush like
fantasy wish fulfillment stuff you get
in Vegas Oh sizzle oh this is a fun
crank caper but George Clooney is
playing the George Clooney role that's
what I would call his role in that movie
oh it's playing George Clooney 12 Angry
Men is one of the most gripping movies
ever made its able to take 12 people in
one room and make that an edge of your
seat thriller and that is masterful
filmmaking that cindy-lou met that is
the cast of that movie I'll go by
ensemble versus your ensemble any day
the week is where the best movies ever
made it's your turn I know I'm waiting
and my ten seconds aren't started yet
time was actually a little bit more
interesting
[Applause]
I'm sorry that it didn't interest you
but I will take one of the best movies
that remain over an interchangeable
crying caper what's casino did they rob
they robbed them in two more movies and
a prequel I'll take one of the best
movies one of the best scripts one of
the best cast one of the best directors
time I love any row that begins with a
very speedy I'm with Daniel as
classically used in these fights as the
second
[Applause]
to watch I have to save Danny got a
divorce the city's and was able to
battle his ensemble versus her ensemble
so I have to go
[Applause]
thank you everybody for being here so
don't forget movie fight is going
monthly the next one is a San Diego
comic-con always a fun one and man you
guys let's all say our Twitter and
Instagram handles on the count of three
one two three please follow us hoot owl
nation and yeah you guys are the best
man this has been so much fun doing it
weekly and I'm so freaking hashtag
blessed and lucky to get to do this with
such awesome funny knowledgeable people
oh boy and Billy Katy thank you for
holding it down and Maura she made us
cookies
[Applause]
[Music]
you